[Inaudible].
Just when you thought 20, 20 couldn't get any crazier.
Y'all are out here trying to recreate the movies. Baby,
a Ponti scheme suspect used an underwater scooter to try to
flee from the FBI. Unsuccessfully it's too much.
If you are trying to fleet the FBI with a C scooter, it's time to reevaluate.
If you find yourself at the bottom of the ocean Scootin, Hey,
you've made a series of life choices that led you to that point.
This man named Matthew Pearcey was underwater for
25 minutes, trying to scoot around with his little sea scooter.
He goes like four miles an hour and the detectives are on land.
Just like watching him. And he's down there thinking to himself, dude,
I'm getting away with it. He saw national treasure one time, right?
Y'all remember the national treasure scene.
This is a scene where Nicholas cage has being chased by the FBI.
And he escapes by jumping into the river and escaping on a sea scooter.
This guy thinks to himself, Hey,
if cage can do it, I could do it. Listen guys, I'm just telling you the dudes.
These are the facts. This really happened. So he's scooting around,
but he what he doesn't realize and what national treasure doesn't show you.
Cause the movies aren't real is guess what comes up when you're underwater
Scootin, baubles,
the DOJ says that Pearcey spent time underwater submerged,
where all the detectives and the FBI could do is see the bubbles.
But the thing is they could see the bubbles. So this guy,
this guy's scooting around at four miles an hour at the,
at the Lake depths Lake Shasta, it's freezing by the way at Lake Shasta,
they thought he had hypothermia afterwards. He didn't,
but he thinks he's getting away with it and turns out they're just like walking
alongside as you skewed.
And you could probably walk that fast four miles an hour. It's nothing.
So he gets caught. He's going to jail.
And now they're saying he's a flight risk, of course,
because he's trying to escape an underwater submersibles and it looks like he
might get life in prison.
He's facing several counts to potentially 20 year long sentences.
So it does look like he will be going to jail for a very long time.
And I say two things. First of all, good show the scammers.
What you get when you run ponds, these games,
number two to the future prison warden,
make sure you don't give this guy a rock hammer.
We know that this is a man with some ideas he might, uh,
get to Shawshank in his way out of there. We don't know,
but this just goes to show boys crime pays temporarily look.
He was banking $35 million Ponzi scheme,
but eventually you're going to get caught.
You're going to look like a full we're going to call you out for it.
His Ponzi scheme was all built on the idea of algorithmic trading,
but there's only one algorithm going on. You gave him money.
You lost money because he spent it on houseboats house renovations,
all this stuff, total scumbag. And it looks like he's getting what he deserves.
Next time you think your day's bad.
Just imagine freezing your butt off in Lake Shasta, trying to evade the FBI,
a C scooter.
Anyway, let's do that. See you next time.
And don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].